you know last week i saw this jeff bezos
he gave an amazing opening statement
talking about his
um adopt his his birth mother his
adopted father
how the father adopted him and just his
rags to riches story
uh and he he talked about how hey
we have this third-party ecosystem and
people internally didn't want us to
create it
what did you think overall because of
his performance because they are such a
small amount
of overall commerce they're a
significant
amount of e-commerce but they seem to be
the op
the most open and level playing field of
any tech giant so
how did you when you saw his performance
graded
so the i'm not sure i'm not sure the
word performance is the word i'd use
but explain let me start with
what i know when i think about amazon
what i think is first of all here's a
company that
has opened up a platform that has made
tens of thousands of people millionaires
and have given
hundreds of thousands of people their
livelihood
and for the most part it's been a pretty
fair shake it's not perfect but it's
it's pretty darn good if you go you sell
a good product you get a good result
in the last two years they haven't
raised fees you know i think they raised
shipping fees two percent this year or
three percent
and they haven't raised their referral
fees which is a bigger profit center for
them and they actually lowered them the
year before last
so they've they've built this ecosystem
which has made a lot of people
um has put a lot of people in position
put themselves through college or
you know pay the rent or whatever it
happens to be and
you know instead of there being sort of
discussion about
how what they've created is is you know
perhaps the greatest entrepreneurial
wealth platform in history
there's all this talk of you know the
fact that one percent of sales
are amazon house products or you know
something might be inequitable in it and
you know it honestly it makes me angry
because
you know when you think about
like think about and i don't know what
your experience has been like for the
last 90 days but i can tell you you know
my house is littered with amazon
packages
oh my god it looks like my house my
garage looks like it's a ups depot
i mean it's ridiculous all right so
you've got somebody
somewhere managing a nationwide set of
distribution centers where people
potentially get sick
with people who have real families real
causes real lives
and somehow or other in the midst of a
world in which everybody else is
shutting down
you're staying open and you're
delivering products to every family in
america
everybody in america is getting some
hard large percentage of what they need
from amazon
right and what you don't see on the
front pages of the newspapers is
thank god for amazon you know thank you
capitalism
right what we should be saying we're
sabbatical on this
we are so cynical now that we look at
jeff bezos's net worth and forget about
the net contribution he's made to
entrepreneurship
and all of those millionaires you're
talking about and all that opportunity
he could at the snap of his fingers turn
off the third party program
or have never approved it we should be
thanking him
and for for what he's built and it
drives prices lower right
you have the most at stake and you
appreciate him
enough to build a giant business on top
of his platform
look i mean i'm i'm obviously thankful
for what
amazon has done because it's enabled us
to do what we've done um
but even before that you know i was a
consumer i you know
you buy something on amazon it costs
less than it would have cost you i was
right there was a study somewhere i
can't remember i think it was one of the
feds
that said that you know maybe 100 or 120
basis points of inflation were taken
away because of amazon's pricing
think about that you know i mean
everybody in the united states pay one
percent less for everything they buy
you know for huge it's huge it's
mentioned well i mean and this is why we
can't understand why
inflation doesn't arrive on american
shores
and i think you and i are of similar
ages i mean
in the 80s you could buy a pair of jeans
for 20 30 bucks
and now here we are in 2020 and you can
buy a pair of jeans for 20 bucks
like what has happened in the world i
mean while education and housing
and healthcare all of them highly
regulated have gone
you know up extraordinary percentages to
the point in which nobody can afford
college
healthcare or a home then you look at
goods and services they're the only
thing that can cheaper i mean what is a
flat panel cost today a
flat panel tv is like 200 dollars
you're carrying a computer in your
pocket that's more powerful than
anything existed five years ago
right and every computer on the planet
in 1990 in all likelihood
um 98 of the people in america
have have phones i mean it's but yeah so
i mean
that's a very good point no we should
stop on it josh i can see your
frustration i am feeling the frustration
as well
we are a bunch of entitled uh
americans who are too cynical about
capitalism the fact that
everybody's standard of living has gone
up because prices have come down is
something
to celebrate